It's very important that your application is correct,...
...accurate and complete.
Since you're going to be asked about your previous education...
...and employment history,...
...take the time to find out any names, addresses, phone numbers,...
...and dates of employment before filling out the application.
Have at least three references available.
Make sure you have their permission before using them as a reference.
These people can be teachers,...
...members of an organization you volunteered for,...
...or previous employers, don't use family members though.
Using blue or black ink, fill out your personal information...
...like your name, address, and phone number.
When writing leave enough space between each letter,...
...so the words are easily legible.
Be conscious of how much space you are given.
So don't write too big or too small.
In the education section, write down the most recent year of education first.
Include vocational school and training programs...
...as well as college and high school.